so where we begin is we look at this and
we're looking for angles that are
solutions angles that if I put them in
here will make this equation work okay
so that's why the first thing I look for
is a base angle okay to find out the
base angle I don't worry about the sign
I look at that and I think 10 of some
angle is 1 now this is a nice number
I've give it I'm sticking with the nice
numbers so you may know this number off
the top of your head but if you don't
what do you do you reach through your
calculator and in this case in your
calculator you're going to whoop s--
you're going to put in this all right so
you're shift tan you pop in this value
here without the plus or minus and you
get one angle okay to find out the base
angle the base angle is an acute angle
it's it's small it's from naught to 19
okay now if I want the acute angle then
sign in constant and do you see what
that what remember what the a stands for
what is a so for all sign it it sort of
says for acute sine and cos and tan are
all positive in this quadrant up here so
that's why we have to think about the
positive number because I want the small
angle that comes up here I'm going to
come back to why we do this and how much
of this you need to understand this is
how much you're going to do I will come
back to that at the end of the ceremony
okay you've got the base angle now it's
45 what do I do with this base angle
what what follows this little phrase
that I've begun here 10x is has a minus
sign on it so tan X is negative what
that means is you can identify the
quadrants where you have solutions and
by the way I am I realized I'm looking
my video yesterday I forgot to do this
it's probably a good idea since we're
talking about quadrants just to write
the letter Q that indicates cuz I'm
going to put two numbers here right that
indicates I'm talking about quadrant
this and quadrant that so maybe you want
to start doing that just like I am 1 2 3
4 which quadrants has negative this is 1
2 3 4 2 is good and 4 is good too
and four so on four are you with me so
far
did you see why I did this was that part
okay okay so yes let me clean Shh
so this comes down to understanding what
this diagram means okay let me just get
rid of these numbers for a second the a
and the s and the T and the see what
they refer to is hey which of these trig
functions is positive in which quadrant
okay so for example in the first
quadrant sine of any angle in their
cause of any angle in their and tan of
any angle in there you will always get a
positive okay if you come over to the
second quadrant if you have angles
between what and what between 90 and 180
degrees um pick an angle any angle
between 90 180 give the community sample
150 is what I heard okay hundred 50 if
you type in good you get your calculator
type in cos 150 go ahead what you should
notice is it's a negative number right
negative zero point blah blah blah blah
try 10 150 now what's that it's negative
what is it actually
Oh point five blah blah blah blah blah
right both of them a negative but if you
do sine of 150 I think you'll actually
get a half is that correct sine is the
only one that's positive the other two
are negative okay so I can keep on going
around the quadrants in this third
quadrant what's the angles from 180 to
270 only ten is positive if you picked a
random angle from 180 or 270 right sine
and cos will both be negative okay and
then in this last quadrant here only
causes positive sign in tanana gear okay
so if I want to find out where 10 is
negative I eliminate the places where 10
is positive 10 is positive up there and
it's positive here so it leaves me with
quadrant 2 and quadrant 4 how's that
fitting with your brain is that okay
okay now we're about to write the answer
out I'm in quadrant two and them in
quadrant four I might actually put in an
extra line if working in here just so we
can see what's going on in quadrant two
we have obtuse angles right so every
single one is 180 degrees take away what
the base angle which in this case is 45
what about the quadrant four how do you
get angles in this corner 360 takeaway
okay does that make sense
so I can now evaluate what these are
that's 135 and that's 315 is that okay
of course you've got your calculator
there so if you punch in ten of 135 or
10 or 315 you should get the same
negative one is that okay that's right
okay help me out
let's do B together I'm looking for a
base angle root three on two hundred
three hundred three on two that's 60
degrees 60 degrees okay it's 60 you can
go ahead you can try it you can put in
sine inverse off yep you don't worry
about the negative to find the base
angles okay now what's my next step I'm
worried about the plus or minus of sine
so I'm gonna say sine X is its negative
so I need to because I destroyed my
quadrants diagram okay I'm just gonna
draw another one where is sine negative
three and four three and four quadrant
three quadrant four okay
so now I need to work out what does the
base angle 60 what does it look like in
Quadrant three in Quadrant four what's X
okay here in Quadrant three it's 180
plus 60 very good
okay no it doesn't cuz you get different
angle the end if angle you need to
remember at this point you need to
remember okay absolutely you would just
like if I asked you to solve this
equation and you only told me that X is
equal to five and not negative five
then yeah you haven't gotten the whole
solution does that make sense
same deal here on Quadrant four we just
did this quartering for is 360 takeaway
okay so our two answers fantastic okay